what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and welcome to
the pregame
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos as you
guys know if you've watched two or more
of my lives and you do not subscribe we
have beef okay
okay guys so our sponsor today is
cooking with chris cooking with chris
offers a completely customized meal plan
um basically you give the guy foods you
already like and he makes you a meal
plan based on foods you already like
that helps you lose weight i lost 20
pounds in the last two months on his
meal plan i've been trying to lose
weight for years unsuccessfully honestly
guys like
this i would not recommend this
meal plan so much if i didn't like it so
much so the link to that is in the
description if you buy it it helps
support the show
um
okay so to start the show today
why doesn't everyone go around to your
name your age your relationship status
and where you are from
hey guys so my name is sterling aka
gypsy
aka local giza
aka the shadow
and so i'm a music manager
i'm a
entrepreneur
i'm a activist
and i'm just here to really just talk to
my people and
yeah that's why yeah and i'm from north
london
um
yeah man and yeah i'm nice to see you
guys man i'm gonna talk sure uh i go by
the name of nizi
i'm from barkin
21 and yeah i make music i rep i want to
rap inside
my girl by the name dell
i'm from enfield upcoming artists
yeah for a point of view shout out also
i'm single
[Music]
i'm from florida um media professional
and
yeah
oh i'm single by the way
i'm d from 1833
um i'm the granddad of room i believe
i'm 37
i work and yes i'm single
okay so um the topic tonight
is send the baby mamas back to the
streets um so
so so i want everyone to go around and
say whether or not you would date
someone with kids um and girls too like
everyone says
yeah yeah so
so i'll
yeah just yes or no to start so i'm
gonna start um i would not date someone
with kids
and say if you have kids too sorry were
you gonna say something okay what do you
mean by date just like sorry sorry um
seriously date okay yeah yeah
no i would not date someone with kids
i mean howard
at the end of the day like
is what it is you know i'm saying we're
human so yeah man if you've got kids
then i'll take that baggage
it's not that deep like what actually
grows you get it but yeah
yeah
personally um it depends on how the
person is if i see like a
future with that person or something but
i don't know
i probably know
but it depends on it you know i'm saying
it depends who is
so if if it was the right girl you might
yeah if it's the right girl what if she
had three three different baby daddies
that's when it gets tricky though i
don't know that one is okay though you
know what i'm saying like what that one
is actually okay one but two two
what if it's the same dad with two kids
i mean at the end she just has to have a
you know her head screwed on that's what
really matters but if she's just around
the way she's got a baby you know what
i'm saying
don't make sense okay
yeah i would say it depends um but
maybe more towards no um at my current
age
more towards no right now
um simple answer yeah i would
no
okay
so um towards the people that said yes
so you
kind of you to yet yes um
why
but yeah as i said just a
maturity level
just knowing that it is what it is and
you know it's i can't fault her for that
she's got kids
me is that if it's the right person you
know i'm trying to say
that if it's the right person then i
just feel like hey let's go i want i
want to build this girl like her kids is
like i'm gonna have to just
take that you know i'm saying take it
with it but like no no disrespectful way
but this i would do that it just depends
on the girl alien shitty
um i said yes only because like
if it's someone that you're in a
relationship with obviously you know
you're working to combine your lives
either way um and everyone has their own
baggage in the sense in life um but it'd
be something that we'd have to work
together i don't think i just want to
have like endless like step kids or like
i don't know it just depends because i'm
not going to be like oh i'm your mom
i'll just like yeah because like you
know like some people it's like
they're like oh like i'm going to be
their parent or some people are like too
like oh no [ __ ] the kids but i think
it's like a balance between do you guys
think that um
baby mothers um especially ones that
like left the dad are selfish
because because um if you have a kid
that grows up in a single parent home
they're more likely to be drug addicts
more likely to be criminals they're more
likely to be run away it's like every
negative statistic you can put a child
into you put them into by raising them
in a single parent home like 70 of
juvenile delinquents are teenage
runaways
but it depends why she left him though
like she's not selfish for leaving him
because she was abused or he wasn't like
treating her right or the kid take out
maybe take out abuse so like outside of
abuse okay but like arguing a lot that's
not a better environment for the kid to
grow up but either way
like you don't leave a man for nothing
like that you have a kid with we just
say bye
so she left the man nanda kids
yeah well no she could have taken the
kids but
because the problem is like when a girl
leaves and takes the kids um
they she gets the kids 80 of the time in
child custody court
so you only have a 20 chance of getting
custody of your kids and if the
mother denies the dad um visitation
rights like he could be it could be
months before he sees the kid
i did i did not actually know that i
need that as well but um with that just
elaborate on that i just say it's like
i feel like people just live in the
moment you know what i'm trying to say
so a lot of these things is just like
like like if your mum right now like
you're not thinking raw me not being
with this person is going to affect my
child you know i should say you're just
living in the moment just trying to
patent up what you're trying to patent
and it's like you might go off then
years go on
that's when things start to affect you
know i'm saying every no one does things
intentionally but you still do it you
know i'm trying to say but don't do you
think living in the moment is conducive
for building families what do you say do
you think living in the moment is
conducive for building families
um
i don't know like basically i won't say
that because it's like living in the
moment it's like taking care of little
things so say like your little father
son
taking care of your kids and that like
making sure he's reading and making sure
to say them little moments like actually
being in the moment not just being a
father and coming back from work and
going upstairs and yeah you know i'm
trying to say just really more to it
there's more to it so it's like i feel
like living in a moment is the thing but
it's like you get lost in the moment
because
it's the presence there's future in this
past you know i'm saying but we're
always in the moment so it's like
it just mingles with everything just
it's you know what i'm saying it was
precious
i'm sorry i was wrong
but i understand where you're coming
from because i've made decisions
um in the moment
um and i regret it now yeah um so i
understand your question i'm sorry um
no continue continuing and saying i'm
excited but i totally disagree on that
because i just think um the woman's role
like in a family is to nurture the kids
to take care of the kids
as a man as
wait what did you do is to protect
to provide
and to take
responsibility but why did you just did
you disagree with me yeah what did i say
it was like you were talking about the
uh what was we're not talking about
talking about the
should again they've been in the moment
[Music]
at the moment
because like
i i just feel like a lot of times
families get broken up because it's like
two selfish people that want to break up
for stupid reasons like like i think
fighting is a stupid reason because you
don't have to fight it takes two to
fight you can choose not to fight
so if you're if you're like if you can't
like you should figure out a way to
figure it out before you break up a
family and put your kid at every
statistical disadvantage that could be
put in
so like if you if you choose to break
that up
like that's that's selfish
basically i feel like but i feel like
some
obviously a baby's born but some
religion was never built on love
you know i'm saying so that's what
happens that can happen but if you
already know when you're having a baby
and it's like this relationship's not
build on love you don't have to then the
co-parent has to
strongly that that relationship has to
boo but some people just try to fake it
and just then i was in but that's good
for kids
it's not good for kids i think it's good
it's better for kids to have two parents
in the home so if they
have to fake it that's better for the
family
like like do you think that all of our
grandparents generations their
foundation was built on love no but it's
about duty it's true like it's it's
about building something bigger than you
yeah that's where i was gonna come in so
i wanted to jump in a few things a few
submits said so
when they're first when they say come to
your point
well let's take it back a level uh a
step back um
[Music]
you shouldn't really make decisions
based on the emotions and feelings so
you live into them living to the moment
when you guys presented but that's what
you should because
you are bound to make poor decisions if
you base things on your feelings because
feelings change 100 so you should do
things based on a rational decision
so it always thinks for if you think
things through then you'll likely see
but you like a chess game you see a
couple of steps ahead you make the right
choice you might go you might not always
get it right but he's going to always
think and think about and understand how
it got to that point if you base
something based on how you're feeling
right now today you might be pissed off
today mm-hmm exactly something stupid
sorry bro you might do something stupid
you might be feeling happy make a wrong
decision and so that's one thing that
also leads back to
um certain relationship in the first
place so you mentioned about have
relationship based on love well i would
argue relationship needs to be more than
just love that's what we were talking
about last time on the show that love
isn't enough
there's not enough because again love is
another emotion emotions change i have a
theory that in any relationship if you
look at like like a um
see-saw
and you're never in love with somebody
50 percent in the relationship none of
you neither you were ever 50 percent at
some stage in relationship you're going
to love your man more than he loves you
and you're going to love your woman what
if she loves you and that will change if
if you do it for 10 15 years you may go
70 31 one for a few years may swing
about another way but you're never going
to be on equal because always going to
be a part in that relationship where
whenever you're more into the other one
than the other one is and that will
fluctuate in the relationship status
yeah that makes sense yeah
so we've got two things here
um
relationships should be based on one
another's love if you base relationship
with love then you're probably doomed to
failure and if you're not if you think
about leaving someone about and just
based on an emotional state then you're
probably doomed to failure as well
second thing is and this is probably
more controversial what i'll say is this
i'd argue that especially
in the in the younger years
what happens is
women often put choose the wrong guy and
she's the wrong guy to have babies with
like every guy you need every day you
date is the guy to be settling down
about everyone what i've noticed as an
older person is that women are more
likely to have
or more likely to have a baby to someone
than to marry someone i think that makes
no sense because
having someone's surname
is less of an issue you can get divorced
and move on
but you've got someone's child you're
there for like 18 20 years locked in the
rest years right
you got to share about them right but i
noticed that girls said that very very
lightly they'd rather have a child then
get married i don't i do get what you're
saying but i think the the misconception
with that is is
say if you were to get pregnant it's not
like most people that are pregnant they
become pregnant on accident so what kind
of stuff
go for it this is the uk america
yeah condoms are free birth control is
free yeah abortions are free i get that
but i'm sure there's no mistake there's
no accident
yeah a lot of people are ignorant and
i'm not saying oh no you cannot be here
what i'm saying is people like have sex
uh very stupidly she's right rather the
point that birth control is yeah they
can use condoms people don't care and a
lot of like a lot of guys oh i don't
care like oh it feels better and i'm not
saying that like yeah that makes it any
better i think that that's the
difference however ultimately ultimately
i have reason about guys but ultimately
who's whose responsibility is it because
no no no no no no no hang on hang on
dude before i say something but before
you react listen i'm saying to you all
right
it takes two to have sex yeah right two
to make a baby
only one person can choose to have a
baby
okay but that doesn't
what did i say
two people have sex two people make a
baby well only one over if we have sex
you get pregnant yeah i make the
decision yeah choice do i have if i if i
have no choice if you want to keep it
you don't want to keep it and you have
an abortion what can what rights do i
have nothing right so who chooses have a
baby
listen though
when you put your dick inside of her you
know the girl does it is a hundred
percent the girls i don't agree with
that pregnant it is not the guy's fault
because we control access to sex so he
could say oh i don't wear a condom i
don't want to wear a condom but unless
you were assaulted that's a different
that's a different scenario but assuming
it was consensual sex you were in
control of sex you were in control of if
he wears puts on a condom or not
so like he doesn't wear a condom and you
said no
is that ripe
well he said if
say you have sex with myself you have a
sex right he said to me d put a condom
on and i said no no no no no and then
you still
right yeah but if i if you were that's
rape right yeah yeah if you refuse to
say grapes so great sorry great sorry
grape grapes
great great great right
so if we have if we're having sex and i
said i don't want to wear a condom but
you allow it
who's who's whose final responsibility
is it
i still think both because you are also
aware that this child might be created i
can walk away
okay well that sounds like a you problem
why are you walking away because you're
pregnant and i'm walked away so how is
it my promise is your problem yeah first
is you're not no one is having sex by
themselves
it's literally a hundred percent you're
misunderstanding what i'm saying
no i understand what you're saying if
you have a kid like you're in control of
everything
so how can you blame the guy when you
you let him in i would never blame him
exactly you're equally responsible it's
that's just common sense
you unless you're infertile there's
always a chance
no you're laughing there's always a
chance for someone to get pregnant while
you're having that's true rather you are
intending to become pregnant from that
action it is always possible so if you
go into sex knowing that
it's both people i can't look at you and
like oh we're having sex every day and
it's like oh i'm pregnant yeah but you
can get an abortion you can get an
abortion and you're the one in charge of
birth control
so so like is it 100 effective um if you
get an iud it's like 99.9 so nothing is
a hundred right so but do you know what
girls do when they're losing our
arguments they talked about the
exception rather than the rule it's
99.999
percent effective so like you're gonna
talk about the point zero zero one
percent like why
like the one person but i still like i
understand what you're saying it is my
child
but i still think their responsibility
is there for a man
when you decide
listen when you decide to have sex with
me okay
the
possibility of a child being created is
there a hundred percent exactly right
hundred percent of the people like it
exactly 100 percent agree that i agree
with you
so if you want to avoid this don't have
sex don't have sex but what i'm trying
to say i'm trying to explain to you say
sex
i'm trying to explain let me put it let
me put it a different way
i drive yeah right
is zebra crossing
right um you know that if you step in
the debra crossing i'm supposed to stop
but before you step on separate
questions you look both ways just to
make sure the car is going to stop yeah
why
to be safe because if you you know that
a car can hit you and still kill you
even i'm supposed to stop right um
same thing i'm sorry that was a bad
comeback no no
it makes sense because what happens is
where we're having sex right
you know we're both responsible as as
again energy as a car i'm supposed to
stop for you at zabro crossing
but your responsibility is still to
check the road because if you don't get
a road you can school it in october your
responsibility when we have a sex is to
make sure that you're safe and you don't
have a baby if you don't want one
because you know if i [ __ ] off since my
french you're literally pregnant you're
still pregnant by yourself
that's what i'm saying to you we make a
baby together
you should to keep it i have no choice i
want to keep it but if you want to keep
it you need to make sure that you i'm
going to be around because i can walk
away tomorrow and you'll never see me
again
and that is burden left on you
so you to make sure you know
for yourself
oh yeah for yourself that the person
sleeping with hundred percent it's gonna
be around yeah well i said all i've said
before previously is i think women take
that that's a little bit too late and
then and then this is like where it goes
back to like
oh that's selfish behavior
it's selfish behavior because you're
putting you're putting a kid in a bad
situation because of what you want to do
in the moment so it's selfish
and that's why i find like a lot of like
a lot of single moms are selfish no but
you know what i'll say is i feel like
sex itself is like
though like the crew is not
that respected on the creation level you
know i was trying to say like oh yeah
we're having like when you have six
you're making a baby it's more like yeah
let's just have sex you know what's
gonna say
so that's that's how i was coming across
like that's why these things are
happening yeah i know but like
like but we have all the information
even like at a young age people know
what content
people know about food because they just
choose not to do it and i feel like it
goes back to like what's happening on
the media as well i feel like the
influence in the younger you know saying
younger generation so it's like you know
how it is when you're younger you know
what i'm saying so if you're having sex
and all these type of things that you're
not going to be having it's safe you
don't know what you're doing you don't
like this you know i'm saying it's just
all of it and i feel like i realize as
well our generation our age like 19
20 year olds
even younger than that like they'd be
actually having babies and it's like you
can tell that they're doing it out of
them
fear
and it's like they want like um
they want a man to be there but it's
like they know the baby can replace that
and give them a type of love you know
what i'm saying even when the guy's not
they even though the father then
like the guy doesn't like her and so she
gets pregnant
no i just said no no
no no
because if the guy doesn't like you by
yourself how is adding another person
that he's probably not going to care
about going to fix your relationship no
i feel like it's like
what he was trying to say i feel like he
was trying to say like a sense of
like
that she can't get love from like the
boy this is that but a baby's always
going to give you unconditional love you
know
so it's like when you're not feeling
loved then you have a baby it's like
yeah you're always with you know i'm
saying
i got a song about that too promote that
song
all right check me so right now on
digital platforms
yeah that was my point basically yeah
no it's just like in my point of view i
i i don't even like put it on the guys
because like we know how guys are we
know they're always going to want to
have sex and we we're of control of all
contraception
do you guys think that men should have a
say in abortion like if they want to
keep the kid
it's in the middle like checkmate it's
up right now in the middle no no no this
is why i'm saying that because obviously
it's a woman's body so she has the
overall say but you know some guys are
like you know like oh i want to keep the
baby in and like
obviously they can't do anything about
it what are they you're not a seahorse
you cannot hold the baby like that's the
only that's the only uh creature i know
that's gonna hold the baby so rather you
want the baby all day if i don't want
the baby and i'm choosing to get rid of
it there's nothing you can do yeah so do
you think that men should be able to
wave financial responsibility for a kid
because the woman can say no i don't
want the baby if she doesn't want to be
a mom so if the dad doesn't want to be
be a dad in like the name of equality
should he be able to wave financial
rights would you mean that way of that
say
so if i get pregnant and i i don't want
the kid i can have an abortion
like the dad has no say in the abortion
so on the other hand if the dad says i
don't want to be a dad and i say i want
to like i want the kid should he be able
to waive financial rights so he doesn't
have to pay child support because he's
saying before it's boring yeah yeah
so i know the states are different but
and it's not like a
what a country wide world but in london
in london specifically lots of boroughs
are
you know if you're as a guy if you get
someone pregnant she can't put your name
in a birth certificate without you being
there unless unless you're married
that's kind of cool
so that's kind of kind of coming to what
you're saying you
there there is still a financial link
slightly if you need those legal roots
of you but they your name is not a birth
certificate unless you are present to be
named a birth certificate yourself so
you've got a little bit of comfort in
that
are you able to change that like later
on like say you miss out and then you
like i don't know it's my kid i don't
know you probably don't i don't i feel
like
i feel like when it gets to the time
everyone should just get serious man you
know what i'm saying that's not
realistic of course but i feel like bro
like yeah like if it goes about to have
a dad then you're in a state
like a man's about to have a kid like
yeah go there pull it on you know what
i'm saying that's a kid's life like you
know at the end of the day everyone
realized all right that's
the best thing you know having a kid is
especially what's special to our parents
i guess like you know i'm saying so
why do you think shotgun marriages used
to work
talking about marriage i just want to
touch on the marriage a little bit
marriage um i think is a deeper concept
to marriage
because like when people talk about
marriage i think like marriage is
it's not just the traditional thing they
make it
sure where they just they just put a
picture
white robe dress everybody dancing clep
and i'm the bride's maid no
i think it's deeper than that
when we talk about marriage i think
marriage is sex and that's why i want to
talk about sex sex is a deeper thing
when you're having sex with someone
it's a deeper connection
it's not just sex when you're having
chase you always transmitting energy
exchange i get a feeling you don't
matter
you make love
so every every girl you have sex with
you wanna you wanna marry
[Laughter]
hey
[Music]
[Laughter]
what was the question why do you think
why do you think shotgun marriages used
to work like in our grandparents and
like great-grandparents generation
if someone got pregnant they would just
get a shotgun wedding they would get
married a lot of times they'd be married
30 40 50 shame because i think it's just
a shotgun wedding is like so the white
the girl got pregnant
and then they got married so they say
like shotgun i don't know what to do
[Music]
for the bride's what the girl's dad
would how to shut the yeah what a
shotgun to the other to the to the guy
got a daughter pregnant say yo
mam i don't make her on this one make
her own someone ever or you're going to
die
that comes from
then how true that was but that's where
it comes from so like why do you think
that it used to work back then but
nowadays it doesn't seem like
it like the baby mamas and the baby
fathers can stay together shame i forget
shame it's back to what he said like
media it's really like to me i think
fear
that goes under shame as well like you
you feared people before you don't fear
anyone now how you study
criminology you said right yeah i see
that
i see that
would you say it again fear yeah i don't
think i don't think it's fear like i was
i don't really know it was though
because
yeah back then it would have been we're
not well for a girl so
in that time back then go out go back
easily
160 years minimum right
fear and shame you couldn't be a single
mom
just about exactly like people talk
about you you'll be disowning the
community who like talk [ __ ] about you
they couldn't be around and just exist
normally
you know
do you think look down on you and your
family do you think that was better
no i don't
think also the difference is like as
time has gone by women are less
financially uh dependent on men um so
like back then it's like well you need
to stay home and take care of the kid or
like that sort of thing but if women are
equally as able to work and
earn money as the male partner i
wouldn't have to necessarily be with you
the only how are we financially
independent if we own two-thirds of the
world's debt
so what's she saying
women women are more in debt than men
i feel like it was because they're only
in debt because when the baby comes they
have a lot of privileges and genders
debt in general just about babies
are single and childless no but i feel
like oh
just dead women just in general women in
general yeah
whether they're married with a divorce
of children no children they are heavily
indebted compared to men i don't know i
feel like maybe that may be university
that i don't know like all of these
little things that just grow up and like
yeah you know i'm just saying it just
all adds up but
i don't know i don't even know
yeah we spend more
more
more though spend more on what though
so you know we're going back to living
in the moment right
women do things based on feelings yeah
advertisements are based on evoking
emotions
all adverts are mainly most adverts are
designed for women even when they sell
things for men they're searching for
they sell things to emote women to buy
things for their men we make eighty to
ninety percent of consumer buying
decisions even though we make
less money than men
wow that's why women spend more than men
and women when because you bite you
don't think about things well
generalizations they're generalizing
here but as women don't generally think
through things they base things on
emotions and so adverts are based on
emotions
and emotional triggers so you buy things
it just seems like as women we have an
issue with like doing things for the
family and this new generation like we
leave 70 80 70 to 80 of the time in
marriages if you're college educated 90
of the time the woman leaves
um on top of that like we spend more
money than men
and we don't pick good guys to make
babies with
that's right like
so so if we cared about the family then
we would pick better men to like make
children with but we don't and if we if
we do pick the guy we leave him
it's hard out here man i feel like is it
because girls just feel like
just
that entitled kind of like to the world
kind of if you know what i mean entitled
to what i think the world is like in the
sense of that
now i feel like um
what's going on these days is we can see
it on social media
like they is demasculating the man
man is becoming
feminine
so what is happening is creating the
confusion
so once the man become feminine is
making the f and making the females step
into a step into a zone she don't really
have to step into it so she has to step
into that more masculine frame so she
has to really step up and do things you
know like take care of the family
protect
provide
you know the single baby mama so that's
what they got to do
and it's deep
and that's what i just wanted to say
you've grown up seeing it as well like
you feel good after you've seen your mom
do it then
it's just a norm you know i'm saying
this is a north side
i agree with what you said but i think
you're
um
rational as to why is incorrect it's not
social media
the social media that caught social
media is a new isn't it new social
medias live around what 15 20 years max
we've had this problem for a longer time
what happens what's happened is if you
get to if you rewind to say well my
parents is probably a little bit younger
than your parents but quite today's 60s
70s
so you had
the sexual revolution
the pill
uh
independence move women female
independence movies and what have you
what happens was that women don't they
don't need men as much anymore
rightly or wrongly i'm not ahead of
caution judgments they decided to take
as much [ __ ] they as they
as their parents would have taken they
decided that
that as we were saying is not more not
duty
it's more about feelings and love of
someone
so
that leads to more family breakdowns
which we're talking about a little bit
here when you have more family
breakdowns you have more single-parent
households so that you get that so all
through the 60s 70s 80s and 90s there's
more single-parent households well if
you're the mom you need to go around a
household you have to be mom and dad now
so now you're raising your son to be
soft
you raise your daughter to be hard
because she sees you being hard and
working hard and trying to be both jobs
she's you you she just you teach your
son to do more feminine things as you
were saying so it's not social media
it's also like before social media
social media just maybe
accelerated it highlighted it more made
it more visible but it was way before
instagram twitter and all this stuff
my brother that's deep i do think women
steve
i would say
leave more because of social media
because they see
it's like because comparisons the thief
of joy so they'll compare the guy they
have to like the other guys
and it's like is that even though social
media is new but we have to admit it's
impacting the world on a big scale
that's why it's there though
that's how they make money that's the
market but obviously of course that's
how we're all connected
it's a big influence in our lives on
social media
she makes a lot of money hey only fans
baby
you go you do you babe
okay so one thing
um
okay
felons have 30 percent more kids than
non-felons
well i said we've been choosed badly
so she's poorly
so i was going to say oh sorry do you
want me to ask you a question here yeah
go ahead do you as women as women head
do you think it was better let's go back
100 years 60 years 100 years when your
dads and your uncles and brothers would
help choose your partner or do you feel
it's better you choose your own partner
now
you go first i think
i think it might be better to
like have the the male members pick it
because
women are not i think a lot in our
generation it's not even that it's like
you're picking a partner you're just
like lusting after other people so it's
not even i don't know you but you're
attractive okay let's go like [ __ ] oh
that's it or whatever so now now it's to
you oh i i fancy you now we [ __ ] or
whatever and it's the next person and i
think that's where it comes to the point
where you're not being responsible and
you're not considering for the kids
because again anyone that you're having
sex with you could become pregnant from
yeah and if you're just like sensitively
having sex with people but okay you're a
bad boy okay you're cool like so i think
it all goes together
um
well i think that we as women sometimes
we like the like
it's like the smooth talker like the
cool you know the cool guy
yeah but he doesn't he's not going to be
a good husband
and so
and so it's like like we'll pick these
men and then cry on social media
oh my god like he did this this and this
but we picked up
justin
what just in the labels the toxic you
seen the memes no no i don't know that i
don't know who that is
you don't
figure
respectfully
you what about you my dad do you think
was better when your parent your dad
would have picked your husband um
i understand where you're coming from
yeah but i would never let anyone choose
who i'm gonna spend time with
i agree with you because it is my role
as a woman
to go through all this and figure out
what's best for me and i think failed
relationships are important because
that's when you learn i don't want to
just have a perfect relationship i think
that's where you get damaged
i think but it's going to sound bad but
i think it's good to be damaged
sometimes because that's how you learn
it i think so no that wasn't like you
ever dated physically
you ever dated
a guy that's like super damaged like
trust issues makes you pay for it
i'm 20. i'm still young yeah okay you
you
i think you have to go through
to be able to get the perfect
relationship that's how i've viewed now
and i get what you're saying like i
wouldn't necessarily want someone to
pick another partner for me but i think
it is better in the sense that women are
very blinded so you could be charmed
that quick and it's like oh he's not
like that or they're not going to do you
like that no you were deceived you were
deceived i don't think we're blinded
like because every every girl i know
that's been in a toxic relationship and
myself included
i i knew they knew we just chose to not
listen like and i'll tell you something
for free uh you you're young i don't
hold you there
so
i've known a lot of women right who've
been relationships with guys
four five ten years what have you and
you're saying well at what point did you
know he wasn't the man for you oh after
a year
so you're saying oh i want to choose
something for myself but i'm trying to
make as we
were given stats about how women are
choosing poorly was it would you say 80
of felons have our felons have 30
percent more children than non-felons so
people in jail have more children than
people like me who don't they've not
been to jail so when you pick for
yourself you pick poorly but then you
have you have you're saying like if so
like back in the days
listen when your parents chose right
yeah
i'm talking from experience okay
my friends experience as well
that
these moms and dads were never
necessarily happy together when their
father chose their partner for them
they stuck together because of fear and
because of whatever you said guilt and
because they have children
my friends now
would rather their parents be divorced
than to be together but they are
together because of the children so the
question that allows you that is back to
what we said earlier on it goes back to
the sense of duty so your choices are be
dutiful and save someone you may not be
happy with but raise your child
knowing that being together is better
for my children
or
not be dutiful
do things your way your pro you're
saying have all these single parent
households because you think you know
what i'm not loving this guy anymore i'm
going to leave and then your child is
more likely to be a delinquent as you
mentioned in iran so those are choices
you could be beautiful and have stable
children
i need to see something on that one talk
to me i understand you completely yeah
again talking from experience then
she made this sofa
because what happened
when the mom stays
there are still trauma from the mom
that's going to adapt into the kid
because the mom is not happy in the home
and the kid
will not recognize that before a certain
age but when he recognizes it
it's harder if the mom
you wake up every day you can choose
whether to like to have a good outlook
on something or a negative outlook so if
you're if you're if you're choosing to
nitpick at your partner or choosing to
fight every day like that is a choice
and see i understand what you're saying
but i still think that it is better for
the woman to leave
and have two households i understand
your statistics
then to just be like oh i'm gonna i'm
gonna live with this just for my
children's sake when the children is
going to pick up on it eventually
it's not about exactly it's not about me
as a mom it's about the kids why would
you put your kid at every statistical
disadvantage
like why would you do like that is
selfish that is the most selfish thing
because you're not happy
you're not being happy as a mom is going
to affect the kid so was it having a dad
in the house
so seeing your dad every other year
you ever talked to someone that like
didn't have a dad growing up like it's
crazy and and and they they're like
every person i've talked to that didn't
have a dad growing up always says like
they wish they had a dad 100
and
like i have i've yet to meet someone
unless like their dad was like and i've
seen it and that's what they do and
that's like they try to break like you
break the structure from taking the male
out because like the dead souls
like he's i can't say that the woman is
in part two but they both
like they both make one yeah i think
it's really what you said like i could
not agree with that more and it's
evident in case of case like
the because the mom is raising the kid
like that the daughter will be stronger
and the sun will be weaker and i just
think like looking at every like when
you said that i'm just thinking about
every single um
[Music]
single mom relationship that i know and
it's like damn that is true
it's so true it's so true and it's like
you cannot escape from that no matter
like you can hear it like i guess
sometimes
like i can hear in like girls and guys
voices i can tell like one parent was
gone because you can hear it in like the
way like the girl is either more
masculine or the guy is more feminine
but you know you can't be divorced and
still have a good relationship with both
parts what you can still be divorced
like have divorced parents
and have good
like good childhood with divorce kids
you can like
but that's not what's best for the kids
so what i'll say to you is this you're
absolutely right it can happen
um but so
what i'll say to you is this and i don't
know if you don't know nothing i don't
think you've done a purpose i've been in
a conversation where people didn't put
salt
i'll say that but i want you to
take a step back a little bit
and
so let me let me let me put a different
way the shoes you're wearing right
right what size shoe are you
four your size four okay is every size
four persons feet as wide as yours
no
some are wider some are narrow right
yeah where's the average size for whip
that people deal with that nike makes
four right yeah right because that's the
eighty percent mm-hmm you have a fringe
on this little bit wider ten percent
fringe is a little bit narrower another
ten percent but we make things
based on the majority of the 80 rule
yeah
so i understand what you're saying but
what we're talking about is that the
majority
there are fringes either side all the
time yeah and that's what i try to refer
to
i'm i i understand that you're talking
about in general
but i still think
that you can
let's not bring up the let's not bring
up the fringes because we don't make
rules based on fringe we don't do
anything in life based on fringes okay i
just think it's important to bring it up
because
yeah i'm talking about personal
experience
that's why i'm changing this let's take
a step back from make not make it a
little bit less personal let's look at
those overall because i understand you
said that before and i understand that
you maybe come from if it's yourself or
you're someone very close to you and i
reckon i see that but i'm trying to say
let's take a step back from that and
escape it away from you let's go back
just the generalization
okay
i feel you but what i had to say about
this i just feel personally like
i won't blame it's not the girl's fault
you know what i'm saying it's not the
girl's faults i did that obviously
especially going back to saying
people that in jail have more kids than
people outside you have to deeper like
they got more to provide for you know
just say so if they're taking more of a
risk
obviously going joe's not good
this is obviously gone
let's be real
let's be real go and joe's not good but
someone has probably enjoyed that
most of the people that are in jail it's
not like they become like
an imprisoned person after they have a
kid i do get that you're saying like
they might have to like like survival of
the fittest kind of thing
but i don't think it's i don't think
that's like it can be an account i don't
think that is the
majority
wait i'm trying to understand what
you're saying so it's not the girl's
fault that she picked a felon
bro i'm like bro if you grow up let's
say for instance yeah this girl grew up
on the block with this person whatever
they grew up in the block like they've
grown up with each other
then after they've had a baby whatever
you get me mama's not really patting
he's trying to pattern up so now a
baby's on the way
like he's a street whatever whatever
whatever whatever predicament
predicament he's in
that he's gonna go and drink and do what
he has to do for the baby that's coming
so if he ends up going in joel for maybe
doing something that wasn't yeah you
know what i was trying to say
is that well he has some he's trying to
put food on the table i think
i think what we're trying to say
that same girl she went to a school
right and in her school there was a guy
that wasn't a road man
the guy that was a robot she could have
chose who who liked her but she didn't
choose him she chose a roadmap instead
so she chose the guy that was that
wasn't that wasn't the best fit for her
she showed the guy who had the
it goes back to like selfish reasonings
because if you're creating a child it's
not about you so when you're choosing
someone to sleep with and create a
family with you have to think about your
kid
so a dude that's in the streets and like
so when you're 16 let's say for instance
you get
um you have a baby that's 17. when
you're 16 are you going to be thinking
how we're talking right now we're not
going to be thinking about it you're
just going to you're having sex yeah
yeah but bro
you grew up watching it on tv this is
that like
your brain's been influenced
there's a chance for you to have
pregnant like i have a pregnancy so if
you're not ready to be a parent
don't have sex like that's the best
thing i can say because either way
whether you like it or not it's possible
it's always good
but if you're having safe sex it's not
going to be possible that's going to
make it so you're having sexy you know
what i'm saying but like that's what i'm
saying that's what really should be the
conversation what i'm saying the girl
the girl is making selfish choices every
step of the way because the person she's
choosing to date she's thinking about
who do i like who makes me feel good
right instead of who's who's going to be
the best husband right
and and she's choosing to have sex with
him unprotected like most of the time
most on people i know that had unplanned
pregnancies they were not careful
it was not like
the baby mamas you guys know
were they super careful and it was just
a one-time thing hell no no
raggedy yeah
i would like to say that
um
yes we choose to have babies but
and yes you do choose who you sleep with
but
guys can do better as well like you know
we could do better so we could do better
it's true
i understand it's
in our nature to actually to hunt oh
yeah spammy's cheap expensive
excuse
excuse
i was going to say men will always find
me yeah
don't get me wrong
i don't think like
these like these boys be wild
every time i bring this up on a show
guys are like whoa whoa whoa condoms i
can't do that
so i hear it but it's just like a piece
but we're in charge of sex and mo as
long as it's consensual like you can
tell them yeah like if it goes it's
happening no make sure you have put up
go and get a condom left yeah
you have that in yourself or if you're
having the that's on you like it's it's
both it's balanced like sometimes she
could be on the pill
whatever
and sometimes mama can make sure he has
a condom you know what i'm saying it's
his balance like yeah that's how it is
you know saying you gotta be a balance
situation because if we're trying to be
safe about it if you're doing a baby
then yeah let's do this okay hold on
guys we're gonna do some super chats
okay so we're gonna go through some
sequences so um it says mic check in the
comments is there something wrong with
the mics guys let me know in the chat
they need adjusting they're saying
okay um but let us know in the chat
where he's gonna read super chat so let
me know like what the issue is in the
chat while he does that
okay sp jack um with two dollars uh
pearl
well you are pending the red pill drugs
c.s brown
as women have achieved more equality
under the law their happiness has
dropped significantly over the past five
decades ladies is equality better than
happiness if forced to choose what you
would
choose what would it be
um it wasn't a question it was more of a
i said sorry if asked to choose what
would you uh what would your choice be
happiness or equality was a question
yeah yes
ladies
[Music]
happiness or equality that's a difficult
question
it is a difficult question
because i'm very for equality
but there's nothing i put higher than
i do like family and all that but um
then happiness
and i don't think i could be happy
without equality
so women in the past were never happy
no i'm not saying they weren't happy but
obviously it wasn't as much equality
they wouldn't be as happy like
we are happier today because of equality
but he said
i know he said that
but i okay how did i say this
they didn't have the rights
before
right some certain rights
if i was to live back then i don't think
i would be happy with not being able to
have those rights that men have i would
send them back
let me go back to the kitchen
[Music]
are you listening but back then you
didn't know this knowledge that you know
now so yeah you know what i'm saying so
now girls are free to feel like yeah
they can have everything but bro back
then it wasn't like that so no one wants
everything it just said equality no no
obviously but i'm saying like girls are
way more they have they can do whatever
they want no you know what i'm saying
and that's something you know we want to
do whatever you guys can do as well like
everything that you think you want you
don't always want until you experience
and see it's not what you were thinking
so what do you want to happen is or
equality
me i'm a very strong person and like me
i i'm gonna have to go with happiness
because you don't have to do everything
i'm a very strong woman and i think i'll
pick the happiness because
well and no one's ever equal in a
relationship even though that's true
even in female friendships like there's
always one friend that's more leading
and one that's going hundred percent
like nobody's equal that is true
is it
[Laughter]
hey
[Music]
definitely hierarchy um sorry continue
with the super chats we have
uh kelsea's cluster uh i'm trying to
impress this young black woman can one
of you give me a tip that would help me
cross that threshold she likes me but
not there yet
[Music]
get your money up bro
you guys drop it on my boy just be
yourself man
what jokes are sad just focus on you
focus on you but if you're trying to
yeah just
dug it just dug it out work hard back
out a little saying
turn her up
you know drop it on please so don't
force it if it feels forced you know
what i'm saying let me let everything
flow my bro but i'm two and two together
yeah i heard him put two in two so we've
got another one hegga j
if i tell you something you can't pass
that information to the court unless you
have evidence recording of me saying it
that's hearsay
okay
somebody has [ __ ]
you have
[Music]
yes motown by logic there is a
biological bias sorry there's a
biological bias for relationships
lasting in average of five to seven
years it takes active work to choose to
last longer than that most people will
choose to follow the biological
programming through
because it feels natural yeah that was
good that was what i said
it's money star women
women want the authority and all the
rights with no responsibility
and revert back to oh i'm a lady i don't
know
no better
you can't have equality as men without
responsibility
as men
i agree
um
[Music]
sean nanigans uh you can't you shouldn't
have
had sex if you weren't ready to be a
parent is literally the exact same
argument anti-abortion conservatives
have always used
the kids dad
yep financial abortion
one keeping at 100.
john cline morgan
i am all for body autonomy but it allows
women to
become far less accountable for their
actions
sleep around it's okay because we'll
just fix your mistakes
quick 504
uh i see you showing off the legs paul
let's go
[Music]
if marriage is supported i'm sorry if
marriage is supposed to be
until death do us part why are divorces
so prevalent and should divorces be
allowed or encouraged what is marriage
my brother-ish that's what we got to ask
because when we're really talking about
marriage i think marriage is a communion
african marriage is what sex is
because sex is deep like i was saying
sex is nurturing i can't make this up
man sex is deeper than what people think
it is
sex
is a one-on-one he really is an actor
you gotta look at his face as well
it's deeper
and marriage is not what they make
that's what i was trying to say before
you got it on camera
like marriage they put it as a
traditional thing it's not that
marriage is when you're having
um
meaningless sex
is just
pointless it's pointless and it's just
ability to create a baby can you imagine
is it crazy can you that [ __ ]
because people take it for granted
that's that's yeah that's your biggest
craze that sex is the biggest how would
you not know that
of course
of course we know it but is everybody
respecting it like that that's the
number one creation that like when you
think of a creation like everything
that's here it was made from someone's
mind that person came from sex
every time you have sex are you thinking
about this well i'm thinking about it
i'm thinking about it
you got me i'm just on the yeah it's not
that you know
obviously when is that right person
didn't you know
are you always having sex with the right
person
no you're not no you're not i'm that bro
bro like obviously we're young you know
i'm young you know
all right so we have um
majority of felons grapes rapists
[Music]
majority of where majority felons are
greatest he said sorry majority of
felons rapists school shooters dv
and essay assaulters come from single
mother households
is that a fact
well uh we we can find out the
statistics for that um
yeah i wouldn't
take it
like even like with that i just feel
like that's a bit like narrow-minded as
well like i don't think they should just
blame
you know i'm saying i feel like it's the
things that influence these people as
well it's not just life this parents is
not home like this parents not at home
you know saying because
all of them situations still happen with
if there's a parent at home or not you
know i'm trying to say so it's one of
them ones but can we go back to what
we're saying about talking about the
majority the majority it's a number so
what i don't know
a lot of
times the exception but we're like we're
you're doing there is you're bringing
talking about the rules sure there's
some
kids that turn out fine in single-parent
households but it's not it's not the
rule
what do you mean
hey
up the super um
um
we have
sorry just refreshing um management my
logic
starts
sorry felons
stats is regardless of timeline it's
just all people who have ever committed
a felon have 30 more kids if the kid or
the felon happens first both are counted
because the trait exists the whole time
this kid's dead
damn it
the pearl from the camera
you see
do you want me to read that again yeah
all right
all right sorry
damn it pearl move that part from that
camera
all right
um the last super chat we have alexander
rahul uh holy
i'm not gonna say that word um we have
got to get this a show with marriage is
sex guy
and ian crossland um i would pay my bank
account to see that show
yeah don't worry we'll do that for you
guys
um
no what they were saying before is we're
done with the super chats right yeah
okay
um basically what they were saying
before though about the traits
is there certain traits that make
someone the hero and it makes them the
villain
that women are attracted to
so the reason that women pick felons is
because of that like aggressiveness
right
because we're attracted to that because
that's also
the trait that can protect us
he has to be aggressive yeah
for sure i i get i do do that i do get
there because girl definitely does
wonder because it's like she does
the talking the situation the man does
the uh you know what i'm saying
you know i'm saying but i say
one thing
i feel like
like girls need to be smart as well you
know i'm saying you want to build both
when a boy that can yeah know how to
control himself but can get you know
saying can get like that so
i agree with you bro but like i said i
feel like is
is like
this is things that man should be doing
really and truly like this is things
that is within every man
and we just got to be just bringing
these things out of us
as a man we should be be able to protect
to provide and to take responsibility to
allow the woman to be in a feminine role
and that is to nurture and love the kids
and
like i said so much men are getting
de-feminized like they're becoming
feminine they're becoming soft
like do you think a man being
soft is a bad thing i'm just going to
say that not that we have a problem with
it but it's like it's just being shown
to us in our face like i'm sure you guys
know law knows x
stuff like that but do you think that's
a bath like do you think lil knows being
who he is is a bad thing yeah it's not i
don't think that is a bad thing
i'm not saying he's just playing for him
but it's like it's just like but as a
culture like as a society like what are
we showing to these people
to the kids
like who who do you want to go to war a
weak man or a strong man
wait wait should you always say that a
little nas because of that he's a weak
man no we're not saying he's a weak man
but it's like the image he's portraying
like young kids you get me there like
i'm not losing it to that so the kids
are listening to like it's always on the
radio and stuff you know what i'm trying
to say so it's like
what they're being allowed to be accept
obviously there's nothing problems no
problem you know i'm saying worthy you
know i'm saying there's no problem but
it's just like there's more more
barriers that just being taken out
you're not insane and it's just making
you know saying this oh yeah that made
up because they're putting it in the
media that there's nothing wrong with
being like men being feminized the
question should be okay obviously bro we
like with the feminine it comes to we
have you have a dad and you have a mum
so you have to have the balance to know
how to treat a woman
you know i'm saying in a certain way and
like to still be a man you know what i'm
trying to say that because you get the
feminine for your mom you know what i'm
saying so it's that but it's just the
balance of it you know what i'm saying
to just have a bit of both because
really truly you're the master as a man
you're
a man version of your mom
you know i was going to say
you know i'm saying so you'll represent
it for her anyway so it's like
you can be but
make sure just a man you know i'm saying
just makes you a man of things
i think that um going back to like what
we were talking about earlier with the
single moms um i have uh five brothers
and i would never tell them to date a
single mom like i feel like if you don't
have kids you you should never consider
dating a single mom
if you really like that person though
like
but you're always gonna like women
release a hormone that bonds them to
like guys during sex
so or no sorry during um during sex and
during like when you have a kid
so
your your future wife is going to be
forever attached to that guy
like i think if you have a kid that's
one like the people with kids i feel
like just saying for instance she had a
baby she had a baby with someone there
whatever she found someone new and that
person she has three babies with him or
four you know saying and those and and
they end up being the best then that
could end up being a star whatever
you're still putting your time resources
and attention into a kid that's not like
that doesn't carry on your legs
bro it's like it's a thing where it
could happen easily because let's say
for instance it happened when they were
18 just to do whatever
they get to like the girl gets to 24
they're not obviously not with each
other but she's learning she found
someone real you know what i was going
to say because
she's 18 she's in university
why would you why do you want to
you
i i don't want to i just i'll just
i'm just on a third point of view stuff
like you know forget about my point of
view forget yeah i'm saying i'm that's
how i but that's our personality because
it's like you have to be accepted you
have to look at life
angles why do you think why do you feel
you why do you think or feel that you
need to accept a woman who has a child
with somebody else
bro i just feel like we're all
black because at the end of the day it
goes to actual emotions you know just
say it actually goes to what you're
actually feeling
let me rephrase this
when you meet a girl on the road right
before there's any emotions or anything
you're talking to her stop numbers
you're chatting what's happening she
says oh yeah i got a five-year-old
you don't there's no emotions there so
the question i'm asking is why would you
continue it's like
it's not even that it's just like maybe
like bro as a human maybe you could see
someone's been
through something i think what you're
trying to say i think what he's trying
to say is i like i think she's
attractive i don't care that she has a
kid if you don't care she'll have to do
this i like her and
maybe then after she told me about her
past relationship and i know like bro
like she's probably you know i'm saying
the guy or whatever like then yeah why
not that i don't i'm just saying that
bro be ready for that you know what i'm
saying she's always gonna want the last
guy
she's gonna see you as the guy that
she's a nice guy yeah she's gonna see
you as the guy she gets some resources
once i see it a girl's trying to treat
me like a nice guy
she thank you that's that's that's
[Music]
you or any of your close friends i have
a group in single parenthood single
mother household or had a stepfather um
i know a couple people that had like
single parents
that's not on top of my head right now i
can't think of but step that yeah and
like to influence you
how do you feel
so
those people you think not know had
stepfathers
how do they i guess it depends it may
depend on the age of the step pepper
came to life but generally speaking how
do you think they received their
stepfather
just she's in the way no i don't
originate nah
that's maybe your people wouldn't it but
my people i feel like they respect this
but yeah i'm saying because it's like
you you stepped up
that's what the whole thing about a step
dad you stepped up to be a father
because you could be a dad a dad is a
sperm though a father you're going to
teach a kid something
no i'm saying the
is that the mom doesn't give the step to
add full control
so she's not going to say oh it depends
when to step there come as well you can
spank the kid
even if i don't want him to like is the
stepdad gonna get that kind of power if
it's not his own kid probably not
and how is a kid supposed to respect a
dad that the mom doesn't even give that
level of respect to
and on top of that like i know someone
that raised a kid for 12 years
and then they got divorced and
he had no legal right to the kid
because
like he wasn't the actual dad
so that's that's the type of [ __ ] you're
opening yourself i feel like some people
get put in certain situations in life
but it's like however you take things
out of it so like you know i say say
like for instance you're in that
situation you're in that situation so
that however you take out that you know
what i'm saying so if it's accepted at
home why wouldn't you just avoid that
situation but it's like it's not that
easy in life it really is
nobody i get that you're saying that
there's like always like you you're
trying to be optimistic about it but her
point is you don't know this person so
if you know that there's a potential for
bad or like it could go as far back
why would you even
put yourself in that like because you
don't i don't i don't know you from next
man so if i see you and it's like you're
not marking or you are marking somewhere
that's not meant to be marked then just
say bye like leave it before you get
attached and i think that's just her
point
like i there's a guy that i was like
pretty into and i didn't know he had
kids
and then he told me he had kids and i
was cooked naysky bye
like because
yeah what your world fell apart yeah i
was like why would you this is a first
date conversation certainly yeah yeah
but like no my world didn't fall apart i
feel like i feel like i didn't let
myself get that deep i feel like as well
like once you get to a certain age of
like let's say 18 you have to you have
to be prepared for people like if you're
not in a if you're single you're trying
to get into relationship you have to be
prepared people saying yeah they have
kids you know i'm saying because you're
go you've got to that age
yeah like this bro
i'm thirty years old
okay
out of the girls
[Music]
no bro bro it's not common it's not
common at all that to be un to be
to be under 30 of no charges is very
uncommon for a woman sorry to under 30
with no children is very common it's not
it's not common to be young under 30 and
have children
like what's your fault
once when she passed 20 is like come on
bro no no no no really i don't know the
new generation bro when you think about
it when we talk about religion
bro mary had when did mary had jesus she
was like 15 children women have a child
that was that was that was the norm back
then when i was wishing i would have
male 2 35. he died early yeah that's
what i'm saying that was a normal dance
so why is it not the normal now just
because these women also stayed with the
same guy
he's a virgin mary
obviously virgin but i'm just as
exhausted
so
what we're trying to say is this
what do you say from say from
them okay so maybe
in there for what you see right in
enfield you see a lot of that right
church but
statistically around the country in the
west
women are not having children young
anymore women they're laying children so
at all all right
all so you're not finding so if you go
out in a in the world you're not finding
millions and you don't find the majority
of women under 20 that's a very young
age or under 20 having children so
that's what we're saying you you're not
saying that women here like we would you
have a baby now no did you ever baby no
like if i were to get pregnant
if i were to be pregnant but it's not
i'm not gonna intentionally get pregnant
why the [ __ ] would i get pregnant now
do i do i have a job
do i have a job
do i have like like
a steady place like so it's like it's
thinking irresponsibly because i'm
setting that child up for failure in
that sense because i don't have my [ __ ]
together so if i don't have my [ __ ]
together how am i supposed to
get the [ __ ] together with plus one and
then also
working um like say okay in this
instance i'm not with the father so
and
we're we're not together so we're going
to have to figure out how to be parents
does this person want to be a parent are
they going to be in the child's life
can you support a family but as well
can you even support a family yeah so
it's like you're you're doing these
things but that's why it comes down to
what probable thing is you're being
irresponsible but what can we come back
to like logistics of just like short
life no i'm just saying like just in
general like shoot lives
you know what i'm trying to say you have
to be like
but that's not the reality yeah that's
not reality so let's say shoot lives in
general in it let's say the girl had a
baby
like who's having the short life well
you have to look at bro you can die
anymore no but you're saying that yes
you can but that's not the reality most
people don't die until they're [ __ ]
80. so you're saying oh like you can die
of course everyone this building can
blow up right now but that's not the
reality we're still here so you're
saying oh what if what if there's always
going to be a what if it's not the
reality yeah like why would you so
because we can die let's just be
irresistible no not even but it's like
bro like you get me like bro
someone like two-pack if you had a baby
dad 24 years old
right now like that's a legacy like
right here
choosing to get involved and [ __ ] that
mate like
like this is all choices
but i'm just trying to say that
something some great people die young
you know i'm saying
that in general just some i think you're
more in the park it's like there's
always that possibility and it's like of
course there can always be just as much
bad as there is good but why why are you
having so much of like oh it's possible
anything is possible so what you know
what my boy has a very
optimistic man yeah i'm just trying to
just bring i'm sure
all the questions are not just yes
you look at things that i see from you
look at things in a very positive light
yeah like if this is that you know what
i'm saying
no you have to hey they're like
no you can't not the eye never learns
not the light look you can be light but
see people for who they are and not who
you want them to be yeah most single
mothers are irresponsible there's my
sister was a single mother like and i
love my sister she got remarried
and like she actually had a valid reason
for leaving but that's the exception
that's not the rule
like most single mothers i meet were
irresponsible and
and it's even more so because like they
they look
that's true
let me let me tell you a story right
so where i come from what am i um where
is that again i live in south okay
one of my neighbors right
south [ __ ]
woman centrist he had 13 children
well in the uk in the uk you don't
matter yeah
as men we is not supposed to have one
woman let's be serious but there's more
girls that be fruitful and multiplayer
so when you go back to african tribes
there's people there over 100
i can see that if the father is going to
be there taking care of these people so
say all three of us we all have the same
like we're all with the same man and
he's equally taking care of us but
that's not the reality it sounds like
this brother is just beating whoever and
these kids are doing like exactly then
for yourself so i get that that that's
fine if that man is there that man is
not going to be there he wasn't there
for the first one why is he going to be
there for five seven eight
[Music]
like it's not practical like i do get
what you're saying but that's not the
reality it's not what percent of guys
can afford multiple wives okay cultures
you're talking about where they had
malta like they said be fruitful and
multiply they have multiple wives like
in muslim cultures you have to make a
certain amount of money to afford to
afford it you can't just have just get
married you have to be up to four the
second one they'll be like dudes making
like 40k a year being like
you think so yeah we all think so yeah
yes it's in the quran yeah it's it's the
crime you can't just have you can have
multiple wives in islam you have
multiple wives we have to be able to
afford to have multiple wives you can't
just have more because you want to yeah
yeah we're due to a responsibility to
look after that extra family as well you
can't wipe your own ass and you're
supposed to do multiple wives multiple
kids
mazeline
maslin what did you say about medicine
yeah come on
another thing to consider is there is a
rise in child custody cases um across
the u.s i would guess it's probably
across the uk too and you know the
number one um like cited reason is for
these custody cases
for is it for mills
yeah it's for the men not being able to
see the kids yeah
well like the mums are pulling that
through the mills are trying to get in
the moms aren't letting the guys see the
kids yeah that's what i feel like it's
just money it's money reasons
i think it's spite a lot of the times
i'll see like baby moms like just not
let the dad see the kid because she's
mad about how the relationship turned
out or he cheated or something yeah yeah
what's up so
do you think they that
women should face jail time for doing
cool
i won't see a joke like i i won't say
joe but just a stricter um punishment
with the government do you know what's
going to say what would that be like i
won't say joe because you're just like
that's you're affecting the kid even
more if the mom's not yeah but she'd
probably never do it again if she got 30
days in jail for doing it yeah it feels
like afraid they stretch them why not
like yeah i'm saying but i'll say
something like
just
money take away from the benefits or so
like you know i'll just say that
i know it's children as well that it
does impact but now you're knowing it
and you're saying it's for a lesson it's
a punishment
consequence like there has to be some
consequence for women doing that
because what will happen um like um tla
talks about this you guys know who that
is lead attorney
um but he'll talk he's um uh like
20-year divorce attorney and he talks
about how a mom in january might not let
the dad see the kids right
and the guy will go to court and tell
the court that he wants to see the kids
and he won't get into court until the
fall because kovid like had a lot of
cases backed up so either a
the mom starts letting him see the kids
again and by the time the court date
rolls around the judge is like why are
you even here and there's no punishment
for her or b it takes him months to even
get a chance to go to court and fight to
see the kid and a year in a kid's life
is like
yeah that's a long time if kids won he's
almost two by the next time he sees them
but i feel like when they're younger do
you know we're gonna remember
no you are
you're saying that but no you're saying
that but i i like i grew up like that
and my mom like was not one to like keep
me away from my dad it was like more on
his side but you do know those things
and
kids kids know more than you think that
they do and like it's true you're you're
young moments that's when you learn the
most you pick up the most even if you're
not saying it
you're observing all of that
yeah most brain development happens
before the age of two that is true yeah
so you do notice that who the kid is the
rest of like and i know this because i
have a lot of friends that adopt it and
they'll get the kids super young but the
kids will still be messed up in some way
because of what happened to them before
they were three years old they don't
even remember
but they have anger issues or whatever
environment they grew up in
and
like a lot of it stems again from like
the broken family so i just don't know
as a guy like you should never sign up
for something like that for sure even i
don't care if she's bad
[Laughter]
like especially as like a young guy you
guys have your whole lives ahead of you
like i don't know why you'd settle for a
single mom no food
no i'm serious
it makes sense when you put it like that
because
yeah single mom like and then you baby
daddy like there's so much issues that
comes with that
[Music]
i'm trying to date her oh i can't come
out tonight i got babysitter i need the
babysitter oh i can't say it i need to
go home for the baby i need to get home
go oh i can't see this weekend that's
not a runner that's not around oh you're
trying to go on a date
schools call me today she's in a bad
mood on your date with her
you're gonna go we're trying to go over
to somebody i should go over a creep at
the house at two in the morning because
you're not gonna get if you leave before
the baby wakes up all this traffic all
that extra all that extra extra work
i'm seeing that crazy seeing that but
let's say first is someone you always
wanted
[Laughter]
it was here and that's
[Music]
she was doing her fingers but no but no
that means you deserve more why are you
waiting around for someone that is not
waiting for you she's settling for you
because
like if you liked her before as girl we
know when a guy likes us
she knew and she picked the other guy
that was who she wanted
[Music]
end up being
way more dis successful than this girl
was gonna ever be you know trying to say
hmm
because women look for men for different
things so she might be like attracted to
his money and like
but like that's not the guy she
like wants one
shoe
but
i don't know man because even if she's
the guy that she's not what but she
could be with the person that she wants
and her life could be
you know i'm saying is that what really
what she wants when she grows up if i
was a single mom and i could just get
the bag like sure
damn
like if i had single moms on this
platform and they i'm like you have the
opportunity to date a guy that's going
to take care of you and your kid do it
100 percent no
as like young guys i'm just like you
guys shouldn't put up with that and i
have brothers i would tell them the same
thing i have five of them none of them
deal with that stuff yeah you got you
guys are young you don't you do like
polishing you guys need to worry about
that like
you're young you saw me just there's
like
everywhere there's women out there you
could you could choose from that that
do not have children so
i'm just what i'm trying to fill what
what a disconnect for me is i'm trying
to understand
i'm not understanding why you'd even
entertain a conversation in the first
place like for when she says i've got a
baby
put me at a woman right we're talking
bad as she is she's got a baby
i'll probably in the conversation not
interested
me too that's the new one
yeah and you don't have to be rude about
it but that's just something that you
won't stand for we can continue talking
but i know that it's in the not going to
start fresh in it we're not going
anywhere this is going nowhere
i would say to depends if you if she's a
bad i might say to her i might ask a
question okay so are you dating
seriously or are you doing casually it's
a casual thing we can we can we can have
some fun
but she better know for certain that i'm
not trying to be a step dad
there's no long-term relationship here
because let me give let me spit
something some spit something to you so
what will happen is let me spit
something to you you meet woman right
she'll say i got charred
and you and i will say oh
i don't date women or children seriously
because i don't i don't want to be a
step dad i don't want children right so
don't be a stepdad
so shoot the natural instinct is because
is is oh it's okay my dad's my child's
dad is in my life
they don't need a stepdad
did i sigh i think for [ __ ] sake
this is like why i don't want children i
have to repeat myself again because
i expect adults to think things through
and a lot of children too and i'm
thinking well if you're a single mom you
should have thought this through by now
so every single month and listen to the
ladies as well if you're if you're a
single mom right i know you i know
you're not now but just play this game i
hope i don't be all right
if someone might be dating seriously
right yeah any man who dates next
seriously you're asking for a stepdad
wherever you think you are or not you're
asking step dad let's play this through
your day
casually it's fine you don't meet your
children
time progresses you start doing things
you start bringing you might start
integrating the child into the
relationship now
slowly by slowly so he goes from
just goes from sleeping over and ducking
out before the child wakes up
sleeping over and a child sees you in
the morning when they wake up as well
then it goes to children's birthday
parties another family event you're
going to with your family unit now
then you're going to moving and living
together
well if i'm living in the house of you
i'm paying off the rent i'm paying for
electricity and a gas i'm putting food
in the fridge
i see your us your child every day more
so they see their father
i'm going to accept that
right yeah you are and the thing is no
because the thing is is like if you'd if
and that's
that's so good that you're doing that
because if you know that you don't want
to like step in there and be there for
that child you need to leave because
you're going to be present so then again
that's another absent father
even even if that is not the child's
biological father that is a father
figure that is there and you're going to
know oh this man don't care about me i'm
seeing you every day how you see someone
every day you're stuck around them
and they're not doing [ __ ] for you why
oh it doesn't make sense and then
imagine that you have more kids too that
guy is is he really going to love that
kid the same as his own yes and then he
can't yes you can't like you could try
your best and you there's
more complicated because i got a chat so
we so again we have a chat together
you're a single mom we get to have a
child
you're one for yourself one i went ahead
before us one so now
every time i want to buy something for
my child
i got about something for your child
what they had before me yeah because
you're saying because then that would be
your child now this is my child but you
have a child before so you've got two
there's two children now i want to buy a
gift for my child but i got to make
something for your child they had before
yeah but no that's what i'm saying
that's why like you become even whether
you like it or not what you're saying
you have to become the parent for both
of them rather you want to be there or
not so if you know you don't want to be
there be a hundred percent not there you
can't be halfway there you start masking
white absolutely and that's what i'm all
and that's what i'm saying
bro it's basically just stepping up as a
father role you know saying is
the question is why are we not find a
woman that hasn't got a child to have
your own family together because someone
can jump into someone else's family
sometimes it's just not sometimes yeah
like when you if you want to talk about
love sometimes
take a step back before you even fall in
love you met someone yeah well not my
experience yeah
that's not an experience
are you a science experiment
why don't you experience that with a
girl without kids
where's the fun where's the fun where's
the phone in there
i'm not saying certainly no oh she's
setting it for you this is that bro
let's say that girl without the kid has
way more
value than this girl that has a baby
at the moment just because the way
everyone's
like yeah looking at like oh yeah yeah
yeah
like you know what i'm saying
um
so so you want wait wait let me just
clarify this thing yeah so you want to
get the single mom cause there's less
guys looking at her no but i'm just
trying to say listen
that's the situation you're like i don't
know i don't have to compete no but then
let's say first that's the situation
like the girl
yeah they're doing their thing you meet
a nice little girl she's a baby mom you
don't really know you find out slowly
slowly and you rock prefer like okay
okay you wrote preferred like you're
wrong slowly
maybe if it's a dad but the mom is there
you can't hide that one that's so
[ __ ] you want to real quick
and i just
okay so let me so your cool all the
problems we discussed that come with
this that this has no swaying on your
opinion
i don't think so
this guy's in love with this guy i see
this
i don't know i've never had a girlfriend
you know what i mean but i you oh yeah
you're you're a positive person you
you're you're
yeah you you were you yeah yeah i'm just
not saying that yeah what about the love
you're all about you know what i'm
slammed there's the best in people and i
find the best in some ways do you think
love is the best for building families
though see it has to be
there's no love bro then yeah because
people people
don't neglect show and love yeah but
then why are you streaming
didn't people date it was mostly
arranged because i feel like it comes to
currency it comes to money like let's
say for instance bro mama has a daughter
he knows where that's the king's i can
right
so stability
so that's what it was for what's the
number one of the number one causes of
divorce is money that is true so
you can't live love stop you getting
your money in it it's just it's not that
easy
no but i'm not saying it'll stop you
from getting your money i'm saying that
if you just make your decisions based on
how you feel you're going to end up in a
bad situation
love isn't enough
trust me it's not enough
it's not still
it's not enough um do we want to
[Laughter]
okay
[Laughter]
all right we're getting some super chats
now um also guys we all super chats are
um
being used towards if you guys didn't
like the audio tonight send super chats
bellroy h uh this tip goes out to the
broskies uh live on the stream shout out
to dettol sb and nizzy
99
masculinity one percent femininity
brackets one percent for empathy
that's my boy and that's what i want to
talk about epiphany that's why it's
deeper than that and that's why i love
how we just touched on on that because
as i said
we all have masculine and feminine size
as a man
so as a man often the mexican side is
the masculine side and the feminine side
is the empathetic side
is the empathetic by i was talking about
so being able to relate to people
being able to just touch into your
emotions and just being able to connect
with people
i think that's the feminist side of the
man yeah but that's what girls
no worries um
the kid's dad
uh red pill
that that's his name that's his name uh
red pill this simp pearl into him to
family court sorry let me read that
again i gotta bring him to family court
to read tell him what does that mean you
wanna go to family court for a youtube
video yeah yeah i wanna see this yeah we
can that would be great content
what is it what is it no it's like will
have fun yeah whoa
just put it on just put this what [ __ ]
i'm buffed on no no no no no we gotta go
to family court oh
oh yeah you can see you can see what
happens to guys with children
so your mind might change
okay we've got a couple more super chaps
uh ballsy
paul why do you let cheska be rude
towards essay
kobe
um he's a great dude with logical
positive messages
i don't try to let her i tell her to
calm down is that my fault she doesn't
like
bear market dating probability versus
possibility it's possible i win the
lottery but not probable so you can't
like
so you can't live like you're going to
win it
i think that was relating to uh the
formal topic that we were speaking about
that
about kills
like finding the best i think just how
every situation you're like well maybe
yeah
like maybe it'll work if i have um
a baby momma and it will be like good
like it'll be fine
like but really when you when you look
at like me
yeah you know tell them tell them you're
out the real ones
uh anyone thinking public is is sorry
anyone think in public is it ears
dropping
all right eavesdropping on your
conversation so anyone thinking public
is eavesdropping on your conversation
i don't get it
um if you are a man of value and have
choice there is no reason to get in a
relationship with a single mother just
have fun but nothing serious
but let's just say while you're having
fun
you fall in love no
i'm just saying i'm just saying i'm over
with that
i'm just saying let's just talk about if
that happens then okay so fall in love
while you're having fun
[Laughter]
sorry no we've actually had two more
come in okay um
jjo uh 40 40. uh heads up thomas sowell
said that supremacists colonization made
africa better
rich to be specific oh whoa that guy is
not to be taken seriously
my brother and that's what i was talking
about my activist side so let me go
deeper on that so the supremacy like
y'all really want me to go deep on there
you make me do that you just tease me
we got
bear market dating
marriage isn't about love it's a
partnership for raising a family if you
don't want a family don't get married
and that concludes who doesn't want a
family though really and truly though
that's just all about life bro that
really and truly
growing up
it's life bro you want to live what yeah
that's your legacy that's your wealth
money is nothing
kids live on the legacy you know insane
so why don't you want to raise them
right of course but sometimes bro let's
just say legends as well we're just
parsing you know what i'm trying to say
bro maybe they just had to have that
baby
obviously that's not the situation but
okay let me let me just
i just want to like bring this back and
like clarify so your your thought
is that we might die at some point it
could be tomorrow
so we should just live in the moment no
i'm not saying that but i'm just trying
to say like just for instance like
sometimes some people
that they had babies they passed away
and them having the baby was the best
thing that could happen for them i was
saying because
it lived on his legacy
just this that like the grandma and that
still have that you know i said it's my
connection
what makes
you or anyone else here so special that
have to pass on a legacy
bro i
is what makes you think that you are
right especially enough in the to the
world that you must pass on yourself i
know bro personally
my family came from africa you know i
was gonna say a woman that come from
africa me just being here and even just
doing this whatever is wealth you not
saying is general wealth because
you don't have these opportunities over
there you know what i'm trying to say so
me being here is that that's a question
of the question the question i'm asking
is you've mentioned a few times passing
on legacy that's passing on the legacy
i'm asking you why do you feel that you
have to what makes you what makes you so
special your legacy must be possible
no you're special to your
how did i parents your name again my
brother call me d
d yeah d you was put here for a reason
yeah this moment is a moment bro it's
really it's really or not but really
it's really bro you got to think about
it bro this moment here really is not
just accidental we're putting this
moment here it's happened for a reason
for a reason something that's not about
you
that's like that's the whole point is
you want to leave the earth better than
you found it hundred percent
you cannot take the money
my parents right they were just two like
farmers right they got married now they
have 10 kids we're all productive
functioning members of society we'll
probably all have five kids each that's
like so many people
and it's like actually really beautiful
we all get together and have these like
family functions
and like and that like lives on
he answered your question though i think
you actually like explain it pretty well
like
he came from he knows what his family's
been in the past
and he wants his own family to do better
than he's doing right now
beautiful yeah that's generation
personally like my aspect because i deep
did the other day like right like i'm
here like i have cousins they watch me
now like you know i'm saying but i'm
here and when i can build up from here
then it just it just goes down you know
what i'm saying because
you know what i'm saying it gets deeper
like i have people um
back because i was wondering in oslo but
not people from iran where i'm actually
from like my parents are from and they
watch like every move i do on instagram
or whatever anything and they're like
wow
like this is so cool that you're able to
like build this and do this
so the reason why i asked a question the
question and the question answers based
on the word legacy so if you you know if
you'd said i want to have children
because i want to i don't know ensure
that i want to
i don't know
help fulfill society in a way that you
know my child may can be with doctor and
help society move on what have you but
the word legacy suggests that there's
something unique and special about you
that has to be part of the next
generation can i just deliver it to them
that's why i question that because bro
you know it's so mad yeah like i never
met my granddad didn't i kind of passed
away like whatever i never met a minute
but
my mind
used to do music
you know what i'm saying i recently i
was i went like somewhere to meet my
family like abroad and that i've met
like you gave me people that i haven't
seen and i've never met them they're
part of my family but it's my uncles my
cousins i've never met and like those
little things i was doing
my cousin was like hey
he said my granddad's name but he said i
i don't know my granddad i never knew
him like that he said my grades are hey
look he's doing what my granddad used to
do i was like who's that so my dad like
my dad just looked at he's like hey
that's your granddad it's like wrong
that man's picking up traits like he
lives on yeah i was saying it's like raw
that's great and i do music it's just
there's like great men that people talk
about generation after yeah i know what
you're talking about it's like when you
you hear about that relationship i've
never met i never met this guy and
people are saying what's similar you
know i'm trying to say oh what look oh
yeah he does music like that was his
passion you know i'm saying i do music
one of my other cousin does music
you know i'm saying it's just
it goes deeper man it goes yeah
it goes deeper really that's how i see
you know
and like i'm sorry like immigrant
parents like they go through hell and
back and then they leave their legacy
like this is my child and this child
builds a better future for themselves
that their parents were and like
um it was impossible for their parents
so when i deepened now i didn't even
think about it
it's so important
so let me ask you a question because
again it goes back to that it might be
i've got a topic but it's the word
legacy down that i feel objectional i
jump to
when you say something's a legacy so let
me ask you a question if you
when you say you have to leave a legacy
behind
if you don't is the world a worse place
no absolutely not so that's the point
i'm trying to make if you really if you
have to if you are so important you have
to leave something like a legacy behind
it means you're furthering
the world you you make something make it
a better place but it's important
[Music]
because of a lack of the next generation
of the work i was going to say we are
yes if you don't have enough workers to
fill the jobs coming in yeah
there's more than enough workers for
jobs not in certain fields no that's not
it's not true it's different slightly
different there's people there's people
available today but they can't do it
it's different conversation though well
sort sort of but i'm saying like like um
i was an economics major you know one of
the ways they would predict like which
countries would take off
population increase like china right now
the one child policy is biting them in
the ass yeah in india they're doing very
well economically
i understand so i should say now not
well
i actually i actually take that back i
think i'm sorry go ahead
um i don't even think it's important for
me i think it's important for the guy
sitting next to me the girl sitting
my right side because
my children
need their children to be able to build
a better system build a better
generation
my children cannot do that by themselves
when i go to work i need my colleagues
to be there when i go to study i need my
students my like other students to be
there
so we are all dependent on each other
i'm not saying that no one should have
any children at all i'm not saying i'm
not saying that at all what i'm saying
is there this is what i'm getting from
this conversation is that everyone seems
to think well well apart from myself
seems to think that you're obligated as
a must
and again i'm going back to the word my
legacy that seems that seems to me that
seems evolved that that that what the
choice of words seem to be very
self-conceited that i am so special i am
so special i must i won't say legacy
maybe i'll elaborate maybe the world
legacy was uh exaggerated but i'll say
generational wealth in it yeah i mean
it's not about money
it's just about making sure the wealth
is still there like it's still going on
throughout the years that i could say my
great-granddad was around
yeah it was around 100 years this time
you know i was trying to say my next
grandkids are going to be around 100
years
like the world would be a future because
they create like they created 10 really
great characters yeah
yeah would they be would the world
notice 10 children at work
yes really yeah the world but it's not
about the world it's about your family
it's not about the world
not everyone can impact the world
fair enough that's what i'm saying
like you never know
[Music]
but i don't even think it's about the
the world but i feel it's about your
family because bro at the end of the day
early family matters that you're
thinking about your family you're
thinking about you know i'm saying
you're thinking about your mom you're
thinking about your family i'm gonna
absolutely yeah
the as bad as it sounds even though i
really enjoy it and i love it but
to the main reasons why i do what i do
like i study and i work and come home
and have to go to bed and then go work
again and then study is first of all
because my parents because the hard work
they did to come all this way and then
give me these opportunities and second
of all to have a better future for my
family
for my kids
none of it it is truly for me
but more so for my family and my future
family
and that's just
how it is
for me personally
because you know that is that even with
that is that like let's say for instance
you start looking at the older
generation you see the difference from
the people that maybe the moms in that
that didn't go to school and the ones
that actually built up someone for their
self and i was gonna say the rest of it
like yeah there might be a nice house
this is that
and i'm saying steep steep it's deeper
it's deep
okay
next question
[Music]
okay um
because my mic off they're telling me my
mic is off in the comments
now is it moving yes okay okay they're
just saying it's off
um
i'm going now
okay
okay um it's just it says it in the
comments i'm not sure with it she is
um well i think that was a good
conversation
um so i'm gonna just go around
you you said you wouldn't date it you
guys same same
change in my mind
can i just touch on one more thing
that's been in my mind
[Laughter]
we just got to embrace this moment right
now as we all hear
we so special we don't even know
this moment here
is made to happen and it's made for us
to motivate and to empower the people
that's watching so the people that's
watching we love you
everybody
and we love you so i just to say this
moment here is deeper and i don't want
to take it back to the boat what's going
on with the government right now
are you religious
uh not empathy i'm not religious but i'm
very political like i'm an activist like
i said so i already stand on what i say
and what i want to say is about my
people so i know there's gonna hurt some
feelings but excuse me
mind me i gotta do what i gotta do and
the thing i gotta say is for my people
as people of color because we gotta
understand black is not a color it's not
black is a frequency
just understand that black is not a
color it's a frequency it's deeper than
that it's a whole different background
derived from the color black that's why
you see me i'm blacked out
because
you can see all colors derived from the
color black so as people of color you
gotta understand that how did we get
here in this moment right now
europe and what's going on around us
so we gotta really just take time
and just think about people back home we
gotta know like i asked my
african-americans all the time my queen
like especially you queen i want to add
like
america
to the point
what is your point
the real point is like
who are we
who is you
[Applause]
know
a game
like we so confused
especially my life is deep i don't want
to touch on these subjects because it's
deep but it's deep
okay it's definitely
so much you can tell me the topic maybe
we can do this yeah we're gonna do this
next week next week we're doing about
race like just we're gonna do about like
that race type of thing hundred percent
hundred percent like it's a race type of
episode though
yeah just like
like the just you will think of
something yeah
[Music]
yes
[Laughter]
i'll go through them um okay
this kid's dad
take him to family court new kevin
samuels incoming
take him to family court man
that's yeah
uh the public as in everyone outside
that room so i think it was referring to
when
i'd listened to us he's saying is
everybody else outside let's listen to
him
is everybody else
listen to our conversations
i hope maybe there might be someone
that's around us the government the cia
mi6 that sort of stuff
on iroscope uh bringing innocent
conscientious into sorry yeah okay
bringing innocent consciences into the
world is to be taken seriously
man in the center talking nonsense
wake the eve up roughly
ricky granzi
step that to one and dad to three but
the only father
but only father to four
uh we all separated in 2015 but not
divorced until stepchild is 18 to
preserve my rights if something happens
to my ex dot dot dot
like it happens in life i say the same
brother p.s i still don't recommend for
single
non-parents to date single parents
because i am an exception to the rule
um pearl your mic is very quiet maybe
something wrong with it
yeah we'll try and fix that one
definitely
um
john clay morgan uh
three dudes sitting near each other
read the rationale um read the rational
mail it it might just save your life and
your wallet
it's not too late lads you still have
time
appreciated
that's why you're on the internet
appreciate you bro and that concludes
our super chats
yeah okay um okay well why don't you
guys go around and say your closing
thoughts
um because we're gonna we're gonna end
the show start from here so yeah
uh so about to apologize i've got a
little bit late
i didn't bring your rum
um rum is my thing
18 33. um we should do a review actually
yeah
well you have your own room no but i
review rums oh yeah that's good
i love it
last time i had the uh
webby park 109 i had some copaly belgium
run but i didn't bring it out today so
apart from that i think you guys are
bring a very positive aspect i'm very
i'm very pessimistic you guys are uh the
opposite to me the ying to my yang you
guys are very especially you can't be
your name bro but you've got the king
you're full of like love and what have
you and i think that's very nice
i also do think it's good because you're
on the younger side i think once you get
older you some of your perspective are
things you think about you talking about
now the demon well perhaps but ying yang
you know saying the balancing yeah but
i'm saying some of the things you talk
about you know being damn single mothers
and that sort of thing i think that may
change as you get older you see
experience things like that but
don't
lose don't lose all of that um
positivity you have because it's not
always not it's not complete bad things
are good to get that sure for sure
[Music]
i think it's like
i i think the main thing in life is we
have to step outside and take our
emotions out and look at it that way um
because when we do look at things like
any situation with like oh i feel this
way it doesn't matter how you feel
because it's not gonna like
change so if you just like look outside
of it and have a an open mind
and look at it from perspective
yeah hopefully
yeah i don't have anything specific um
but i think it was a good chat and
um i respect everyone's opinion and yeah
it was good
um i thought it was a good chat you know
i feel like we've got a lot of angles
spoken about
and saying everyone got their little
mice that their point of view
spoken so yeah if it was a great chat
and yeah
literally
yeah i missed it as well
i like the whole setup you have in here
you know it's nice
and yeah man just us giving our
perspective even though i didn't talk a
lot i'm i'm more of a listener
than talking about very interesting i
think i took a lot
i learned a lot from today from you guys
but yeah man
100 like for me like this is just really
like uh no like a moment to remember
it's a moment to embrace like i'm around
so much beautiful people so much
beautiful energy and we just
caught up in a room
like this [ __ ] like this is just like
this is made to be
and whatever made to be like it just
gotta go and that's one thing i gotta
say like we here for a reason we could
die tomorrow let's go get it let's go i
keep telling my people ready or not
let's go
i tell him you got a bag of you or not
let's go like every day is a moment and
we gotta embrace it
racism we gotta embrace it and we gotta
embrace it and we got to go harder and i
love you all my people and there's
something in me and then say like when i
look at you
i see me and you
that's how i feel that's something
that's happened
and that's what you have to be like in
life you have to see
yourself in the person and where the
person is in life that's why that people
think oh this guy's sitting here but bro
i'm licking i'm looking at like
frequency i'm looking at stuff is
and i'm saying it's all the way down
here and some people are not on the
frequency they don't get where you're
coming from but really true you've got
to look at the person and be like oh
cool i just put
this person isn't like oh dude he's
doing this first he's doing this news
you know i'm trying to say like
different angles you know i'm saying
uh-huh
[Music]
confiscated
um okay guys um thank you so much for
watching tonight um let me know in the
comments what topics you guys would want
us to cover next week um we'll
definitely bring on
um
[Music]
okay um
okay guys um for real though don't
forget to subscribe to the channel if
you want to support the channel um send
super chats or get the meal plan of
cooking with chris
helps you lose weight
with foods you already like um don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification bell we're live
wednesday thursday saturday night and i
will talk to you guys next time